yeah welcome to this video versus legend
2014 the Kings fianchetto week is
continuing so I'm going to three let's
be in shadow anymore why not getting a
double fianchetto in effect yeah this is
a line then I've played quite a bit also
in over the war chess and with some
success i recently had it against dr.
none and i played it like that i know
i'm not sure i would think he got a
pretty decent position back then but i'm
still going to try it out again the
thing is that black is going 45 and you
have to either play d4 to stop that or
or what i just did and ok i can take a
right isn't that quite nice what about
this that's a pin on the C file that was
one idea of Quincy tool and 95 it's not
so easy now it's got it's like he does a
poner doesn't get it don't get it back
yeah Black is going 45 and you have to
play d4 to stop it or put a knight to e5
and well i think d 4 is actually better
but 95 is this interesting leads to
different kind of position really how is
he not losing a piece now I don't get it
night before I have Quincy three acha is
he having Queenie fire fear 25
when I'm trapping the queena that still
appears if I just go back now yet to
somewhere g2 Queen takes Knight c3 I'm
trapping that Queen and I'm a pizza or
is there something better even Queen c3
is just a pawn but that is that should
winner kind of stunt you a little bit
but I think I'm just wrapping the Queen
which is in essence apiece
check ya net gain this is a full piece
so let's see how how to play it most
efficiently getting the center should be
okay
I don't need you to rush things here I
have time to sort things out okay of
course you should win with that piece
but it's no need to to be hasty about it
so here and that looks good getting the
night possibly to e6 yep check here
check and that wins in more material
check black resigns yeah okay just
blundered that thing on the sea farm
didn't appreciate the whole thing here
yeah I think black is certainly okay
yeah i think dr. none did she take a TI
think he took immediately and wendy form
which was interesting kind of cutting my
bishop off here but it's interesting
this position I haven't ever diagonal
that might be useful in the future with
b4 b5 but black has a little bit more
play in the center um yeah I think this
is just probably not so great oh okay
you can take with the Queen yes that's
true that's true that sets probably the
right way to go yeah that's true we can
do that now that feels better I mean
outfits better is is better if I now
it's not so easy now to prevent you five
let me I can still do something like
that but even Queen f5 seems okay yeah
it seems ok for black can I if I go
again here is this a good move i feels a
bit feels a bit strange i do between b2
and piling up on that long diagonal okay
it's playable but this is this is not
really great right yeah okay this is
this is losing right away the engine
wants to sacrifice a pawn with rook c8
just let me take the island say like
this yeah okay my development is not
brilliant so it might be might be slight
compensation
here chicks Roxy one and then Queen B 1
and night night away from I he has a bit
of compensation but it's probably
probably not enough and this is just
this loses the peace simply because of
what I did it's it simply it's trapped
here the Queen and he's already a piece
down here so I cannot just take the pawn
let's say I'm just just a piece up again
so yeah an opening disaster even as the
out of this relatively quiet opening
okay well thanks for watching